All right. Hello and welcome everyone.
It is Saturday, August 26, 2023 and
we're here in Physics as information
processing in the fourth discussion.
Thank you, everybody who's joining live
or watching... Live or watching in replay.
This should be a really fun discussion
as usual. So we're going to have Ander
provide some slides and some initial
clarifying questions for Chris and then
we're going to open it up for our guests
to ask some questions and check in a
live chat, see what people are talking
about. So Ander, to you for some slides
and overview. Okay. Thank you, Daniel.
So last time we were starting to talk
about multi agent communication and lock
protocols and all of that. So let's
quickly go through the slides and sort
of try to recall the main concepts.
I guess just to go back to session three
for a second. One takeaway was that when
you have non committing sectors in a
boundary, that's necessarily going to
require classical communication between
them. So that is more or less the whole
point of today, how noncommittan sectors
may communicate, have to communicate
classically.
Another introduction in this last
lecture was this new graphical notation,
TQFT, if you wish to call it that way
for any of these clock ticks. Okay, so
let's recall the whole process of
measuring a sector environment and
writing it into a memory environment can
be simplified to this sort of tick that
connects two portions of the boundary
and everything we talk about
lock protocols will be written in this
graphical notation.
So let's keep
going a little bit. This slide
is on the paper on sequential
measurements from 2022. These are
basically the formal mapping between
QRFs and topological quantum
field theories. Okay. So we're more used
to the picture here on the left hand
side of this slide, right with the QRF
sectors. But Pictorically speaking,
this is at least how they map.
Okay? And then from then we
started talking about entanglement and
classical communications using this
notation. And this is probably where my
questions to Chris will start. So in
section Three, we saw this
idea of the FEP asymptotically being
the principle of unitarity, aka.
Driving the system, the joint system,
Alice and Bob to entanglement, which in
this graphical notation, amounts to them
sort of completing a
cycle here where the QRFs are perfectly
aligned, so that the S sector of one
becomes the memory sector of the other.
And vice I actually at this point
already, I have a question for Chris. I
have it written down.
Yes. Two things here, Chris.
Number one is in
the log protocol picture we do have a
distinguishing between a quantum channel
and a classical channel. And if I
understood that part correctly, we said
that passage of time or expenditure of
energy, free energy only corresponds to
the classical tick. So in this quantum
entanglement picture where you don't
quite have that, is it fair to say that
there's no such thing as a classical
take no passage of time, no expenditure
of free energy. Is this a degenerate
picture of the locked protocol where the
sectors were aligned the right way and
boom, you got rid of that classical
thing and that's it. And secondly, I
guess, what does it mean for these two
parts, quote unquote from the paper,
to implement a joint
quantum process?
So, yeah, this is not a lock
protocol, clearly, because there
is no classical communication.
And in fact, Alice is
not divided into multiple
compartments. Here Alice is just
implementing this single quantum
process, Q. And because
these sectors are because these QRFs are
perfectly aligned,
we can think of,
remember from
probably the second session the
picture that you were very interested in
under of
the Wick rotation reversing
time between Alice and Bob.
So Alice's clock in fact ticks
in the opposite direction from Bob's
clock because both of their internal
clocks are counting incoming bits, not
outgoing.
In this, in the right side of this
picture,
there is no overall time.
You can think of Alice's clock ticking
forward one unit and then Bob's
clock ticking backward one unit.
So that the
information flow is completely time
symmetric between Alice and Bob. So we
can think of both of these processes,
q and Q prime, as bi directional
in time. That's what it means to have a
pure unitary process.
So no time asymmetry. That's what it is.
Right. So there is no time asymmetry in
this picture. And when you introduce
classical communication, of course you
have to have a time asymmetry. Right.
Because you have this I mean,
classicality is defined by this notion
of irreversibility. I see. Which is just
the same as time asymmetry. And it's
the irreversibility that burns energy.
So there has to be energy flow
between Alice and Bob to
drive what
is from a global point of view and
only an apparent asymmetry, but from the
point of view of Alice One and Alice Two
as components of Alice,
they're the ones who see the asymmetry.
So I guess just to tie back to the
question of the week rotation, once this
joint process is implemented naively,
one can say is this cycle going
clockwise or counterclockwise? And is
that going to define on originally
whenever these guys ended up being lined
up where the weak sign was coming from?
Yes. Whenever Alice sees information
flowing in, Bob sees information flowing
out. So their
WIC rotations are going in opposite
directions. Okay.
Yeah, very good.
The other thing to think of in this
picture, Rich, it's impossible to draw
all of these simultaneously, is that if
you think of the FEP as fully
aligning Alice and Bob, then not
only do these processes perfectly
couple, but the
area that's green in this right
hand side kind of expands to fill the
whole boundary. So that in
the complete limit of Alice
being able to perfectly predict Bob and
vice versa, then the whole boundary is
green. So there's
no this distinction between the
S sector and the Y sector disappears.
Yes, that makes sense, actually. And
just to conclude with this slide, back
in the session two, we saw something
about agents requiring a free choice of
reference frame for their QRFs, which
amounts to being able to choose how to
measure a spin. Right, right. So is
part of this entanglement picture, do
they just have to align the sectors or
also the way they are measuring a spin
on those sectors?
Yes, they have to align the way they're
measuring the spin in those sectors.
It's that lack of remember the point
that free choice
of local reference frame
is required for separability. So as
the systems become fully entangled,
then their local reference frames for
each qubit become the same.
Become necessarily the same.
Thank you. Okay. And then let's continue
a little bit. So in this talk, we're
mainly interested on QRFs that do not
commute. Now, maybe,
Chris, you can tie this back to what you
were saying earlier about if you're
perfectly entangled, then the sector is
going to grow. Does it have anything to
do with this? So if Q one and Q two here
do commute, then how do you reduce this
to the picture on the right hand side?
At the first glance, it looks like the
picture on the left hand side
encompasses more sectors of the
boundary.
Yeah. The point here is just that if
we go back and go
back to the notation where what
we're representing by this simplified
notation is a
collection of cocon
diagrams, and if
these reference frames commute,
then one can take these two diagrams
and find a think
of it in the information inflow
direction. There will always
be a common cocon
over the two sets of input
classifiers if the two QRFs
commute. So what that means is
that I go from a diagram with two sets
of classifiers, each going up to some
apex, to a
diagram with the merged set of
classifiers going up to some
farther up the hierarchy apex because
they commute. I can find that sort
of yet more abstract coconut that covers
all of the classifiers in both QRS.
So that just collapses these
pairs of green segments down to one
green segment. And I've drawn it the
same size. I mean, it would make more
sense graphically, I suppose, to draw
it. Right. Each one is twice as big or
twice the area. But keeping to
this kind of very topological
representation where the area isn't
actually meaningful,
it is convenient to draw it this way.
Right. So in short, commutative the fact
that they commute means that you will
have that higher apex anyway. So you can
bypass that first nesting. Right. But it
comes to the number of degrees of
freedom at the boundary. They're still
the same. And in terms of area right,
okay. Yeah. We're not getting rid of any
of the degrees of freedom of the
boundary that these QRFs are looking at.
Yeah, very good. So the next slide I
found a very interesting one. So these
are no Go theorems things that Alice and
Bob cannot do, and it's mainly having
to do about measuring their own
entanglement entropy and counting
degrees of freedom. I guess
this has a very holographic feel to
it, and also maybe even a bit of a
Goddess theorem feel to it. So I don't
know if Chris wants to comment on that.
Well, I'll just say that I think this
does have a kind of girdle
undecidability feel to it, in that
there are a large number of questions
that Alice can't answer,
which certainly suggests
a formulation in terms of
incompleteness.
And the connection
to Gertle's theorem is actually
something that Jim Glazberg and I are
currently working on,
and hopefully we'll be able to make that
connection more precise. But the point
of these statements is just to emphasize
that a
single observer that's
uncompartmentalized cannot
determine anything about the
entanglement entropy of the environment.
And this is just the result that to
measure entanglement, you have
to employ a lock protocol. So you have
to have classical communication.
And this raises
a fundamental issue in the theory,
and that classical
communication is an exchange of
information that cannot be
represented as a single quantum
process. Hence,
you have language like the collapse of
the wave function or these various other
decoherence, et cetera, et cetera,
these various ways of trying to capture
this idea that something different and
irreversible is happening as soon as you
talk about classical communication.
So the
point is, for Alice to measure anything
about the entanglement entropy of Bob,
she has to be sectored.
So her entanglement entropy has
to decrease, but she can't know that.
She can't actually know that she has
sectored compartments when we think of
Alice as an entire system. So from
now on, we're going to be
talking about the
very limited points of view of
particular observers.
And to talk about that.
I think it's very important to keep
these various limitations in mind,
because there's a real distinction
between what we can say
effectively from this
kind of God's eye point of view that
we're adopting. As theorists where we
say Alice has sectors
that are communicating classically and
what Alice's system can do from
her point of view or her
sectors can do from their points of
view. And this is a distinction that's
often ignored, but it's important to
keep it in mind.
Awesome. Thanks for this line ender.
Yeah. So should we continue?
Yeah,
then I guess we get to the proper
material of the last lecture, which is
what happens when you have sectors that
are commutative, such as two
portions of Alice involved that have to
communicate classically. This is what
requires the classical communication
tick.
Let me see. So would
it be fair to say, Chris, this only
such a classical channel, such as the
one shown in this slide requires
free energy. Is that right? Because
there's some writing into a memory
involved in here. Compared to the
earlier slide where we had that closed
loop in the entangled picture, there was
no expenditure of energy. Is that.
The the example to keep
in mind here is exactly
the process that we're executing right
now.
Alice has two components,
and we are currently in the position of
those components. And we're
communicating classically with each
other by employing
a channel that's part of our shared
environment. So we are acting
irreversibly on our shared environment.
And it's that irreversible
action on the environment that has the
free energy cost for each of us.
We actually have to make noise to
communicate, and our
laptops are actually consuming power.
All of this is classical. It's this
irreversibility that defines
classicality.
Right. And to continue with this
question, I guess it will come
ensure in later slides. But the other
side of this lock protocol is the
quantum channel. And my question to you,
Chris, is just like there is an
expenditure of time and energy involved
in this classical channel, is the
quantum channel basically the opposite
of that meaning its action is
instantaneous entanglement, presumably.
And also, again, back to that loop
picture of entangled cycle,
is there just no passage of time, no
expenditure of energy? Does any of that
make sense? Yeah. And I think it's
worth actually going to the next slide
here where we complete the loop and add
the quantum channel.
Is it this one? Yeah.
I think to understand what's going on
here, I think it's very useful to think
of it in terms of a Belly PR experiment,
right, where Bob,
in this case, the shared environment
includes the source that's creating the
entangled pair, which a
one and a two observe simultaneously.
They interact simultaneously with their
two detectors, which are interacting
with the entangled pair. So you can
think of their two detectors are
entangled, and it's only later
that they exchange this classical
information. And in a Belly PR
experiment,
the elapsed time between the source
emitting the entangled pair and the
entangled pair interacting with the
detectors deployed by a one and a two is
designed as part of the experimental
protocol to be less than the
time that it is required for a
one and a two to communicate
classically. And notice that from
the point of view of the entangled pair
itself, no time has passed at all.
Right? The entangled pair
is, from a special relativity point of
view, moving along a light like
trajectory. So there's
no distance being traversed and no time
is elapsing. From the point of view of
the entangled pair, there's only an
elapsed time and a traverse distance
in the coordinates of the observers.
And it's those coordinates that define
the parameters for the observer's
eventual classical communication.
So this is why I characterized
the assumption of classical
communication as a stipulation and
also why I characterized it as a fine
tuning assumption.
We are assuming something very specific
about this communication channel,
and we're assuming that the
part of Bob, the part of the shared
environment that implements this
classical communication channel,
behaves differently from the rest of the
shared environment. It behaves in
a way that is classical,
but the rest of the shared environment
doesn't. Right. The rest of the world is
described using quantum theory. So we're
making this assumption that part of the
shared environment is special, and the
specialness is that it behaves in this
classical way.
So let me finish with this slide. I
suppose to go back to my earlier
question about that Entangled loop being
at least Pictorically appears to be like
a degenerate version of this log
picture. If in this log picture I have
the quantum channel on the right,
that hypothetical entanglement
to complete the cycle on the left was
only broken when a one and a two chose
to write that into their memories at
different sectors. Right. And then that
eventually necessitated the classical
communication between them. Is that
correct? Yeah.
One could always take the point of view
of, if you will, the observer who's
outside the entire universe and just
sees the entire universe evolving
unitarily. And from
that point of view, there's no such
thing as classical communication. So the
communication is classical only relative
to this division between the Observers.
And that division between the observers
corresponds to their
measurement procedures, not commuting.
So it corresponds to what
we think of classically as Alice
acting on her half of the entangled
state, determining what Bob will,
then that all
of that causal language is classical.
Right.
We're like at 1130. So halfway, more or
less, let's say a few words on
the later slide process and all of
that. I guess before
we start talking about this, which will
take us like five to ten minutes at
most, could you say a few words again
about the fine tuning assumption? So I
still can't quite understand what is
meant here, that this whole classical
communication stuff requires fine
tuning.
Okay. I think a way to think about it
is to
think about what it means to say that
Alice and Bob are able to communicate
classically.
What we're saying is that Alice and Bob
share some sort of language. So when
they exchange their data, we can think
of their data as written in some binary
code in a data.
Alice says,
I set my instrument this way and I saw
this spin. I then set my instrument
this other way, and I made this
observation. So Alice, his data table,
or a one's data table,
is just a long table with two
entries in each row. One entry is how
the detector was adjusted, and the other
entry is what the value of the spin was
observed. And Bob's data table looks the
same. And so they share this
information, or they share it with some
third party, they communicate it
classically. And there are two aspects
to that classical communication. One is
that up to classical noise,
their data tables don't change when
they share them. So they
really are irreversibly recorded.
They're not evolving in time along
with the rest of the universe.
The other aspect is that we have to
assume that Alice and Bob mean the same
thing by
their notations in these data tables so
that they can actually compare them, so
that they can actually do the statistics
and see if they've violated Bell's
inequality. So what that means is we
have to assume that they actually share
a definition of up, and that when they
talk about changing the settings on
their instruments, they're talking about
changing those settings with respect to
some shared definition of,
you know, in a real experiment, that
shared definition of up is provided by
the Earth's gravitational field or
something like that. Earth's magnetic
field, some shared environmental
variable. So now
it seems like we have a
situation in which Alice One and Alice
Two should be entangled because they
share this reference frame that enables
them to communicate classically,
but they can't be entangled if
they're going to communicate
classically.
So we make an assumption that
in just this case,
they share a reference frame, but
they're not entangled. They're able
to communicate classically while sharing
the reference frame. And we
can sort of wave our hands and say they
only share the reference frame up to
some measurement resolution or something
like that. But despite the hand
waving, we're making a very specific
assumption that violates
the fact that reference frame sharing
induces entanglement. So that's the fine
tuning assumption. We assume that the
universe is such that in this very
specific kind of case,
we can have reference frame sharing
without entanglement.
Cool. Let's keep it here
and just open it up a little bit if
Harris or Dean want to just give any
thought or reflection on what we've
gotten to so far. Harris,
if you want to, please. Yes.
Everything is very interesting.
Basically, I was listening with great,
let's say focus. It reminded me this,
let's say, elaboration on the previous
talk that Chris gave two weeks ago. It
reminded me something that Michael Levin
said some time ago. It is
regarding this amazing ability of
cognition to scale up. So it's not only
this understanding, let's say, of the
scattering of cognition, but also the
scaling up of cognition. And when
I tried to get inside my head,
actually, that as Chris said
in one of his talks, that if a
system is a tag wall, one cannot draw a
meaningful boundary across it. So this
fine tuning, let's say elaboration
that was made right now actually helps
me understand that even better.
So thank you, Chris, for that and thank
you Ander for this.
Thank you. Thank you. I'm glad that
helped. Yeah, I think
this is intimately related to the
question of what cognition is since
if we have a purely quantum system,
there really is a deep sense in which
nothing is happening because of the time
symmetry. So to talk about cognition
as something that actually occurs,
we have to think of it classically.
Thank you. Also, if you allow me another
comment on that, basically one of the
comments posted during your last talk
in the chat had to do with classical
memories. And I was thinking about that
and I came to the conclusion that
classical memories presupposes a
gestation period. And when I
think about it, that actually makes
sense. And it is true, let's say,
for both physical and psychological
reasons. So, for example, a hard disk
needs to write data on its magnetic
surface and a human brain needs to
consolidate all those neural connections
through synaptic plasticity. Let's say.
However, when we start thinking about
quantum information and quantum
memories, let's say we realize that such
memories will be such quantum memories
basically will be stored in qubits or
in those entagle states that you
describe. So they do not necessarily
have the same limitations. And of
course, quantum information theory
suggests, as I understand it, that
quantum memories can be created and
accessed instantaneously without any
form of ingestation, let's say without
any ingestation period. And of course
this goes back and it has the potential,
as I see, to revolutionize computation
in terms of quantum computation,
but also, and most importantly,
communication and quantum cryptography
even. And this is something that I
am truly interested in.
So yeah, I just wanted to share also
that.
Yeah, that's a very good point.
And the flip side is the
issue of stability which again
gets to the notion of environmental
decoherence which is just
the process of observation of the
quantum state by some
environment or some observer, some
component of its environment.
And the reason this
is a problem in practice is that we
don't have complete control of all
components of the environment,
right? So we
have to use things like liquid helium to
try to keep the environment at bay to
prevent decoherence because
any other components of the environment
interacting with our quantum memory will
alter the state of the memory.
Yeah, that is
a great answer and basically the reason
why I typed that question. Regarding
super selection rules, and namely me,
I propose something called fuzzy super
selection rules. Basically, as I
understand it, those super selection
rules, the classical ones, let's say
they are based on symmetries or on all
those conversation laws that actually
limit the accessibility or our capacity
to measure, let's say, certain quantum
properties, let's say, maybe it's
parity, maybe it's angular momentum,
maybe it's even charge. But if
we start thinking like these fuzzy super
selection rules in an effort to relax
these restrictions by allowing some
degree of coherence or interference
between the different super selected
sectors, which can be quantified,
let's say, by a parameter called
fuzziness. I know that in other fields,
like in my field, that is fuzzy
cognitive mapping, the introduction of
fuzziness from as it
was propounded by Professor Lotfield
Zadek, it actually helped a lot of our
models to become more accurate, let's
say. So this is what I am proposing.
Maybe of course, I don't expect it to
revolutionize quantum information, but
maybe it can help us understand a bit
better what is going on and the role of
the coherence that comes out of the
environment. So if we incorporate it as
a parameter of fuzziness, a priority,
then maybe we can understand and even
what we are dealing with.
Yeah. I would refer you
to the paper by Bartlett.
There are two other co authors in
2007, a lovely review
of quantum reference frames in reviews
of modern Physics. And a point that they
make that I think is relevant here is
that a super selection rule
can always be interpreted.
Let me see. I'm not sure I'll be able to
completely reproduce their argument,
but they show that a super selection
rule can always be interpreted as the
absence of a reference frame or the lack
of a reference frame. And one of
the examples that they give is charge
conservation, that we never see
superpositions of different electric
charges. And their
point is we never see this because we
have no way of measuring it. We have no
reference frame that we could use
that would allow us to see a state
of superposed charges.
And effectively what they're saying is
our reference frames are all made of
matter that is
composed of stuff that has well defined
electric charges. So we can't see
things that are superpositions of
charge. And it's very difficult for us
to see things that are superpositions of
position. So this
question of what is
a super selection rule, why do we have
these rules, at least in their
reasoning, boils down to the question of
why do we have some reference frames
or some measurement capabilities and not
others? What is it about us that
limits in some fundamental way our
ability to make measurements?
And I suspect that when you
talk about fuzziness, which is
a sense of classical uncertainty,
that you may be sort
of pointing in that direction, but I
think it would be worth looking at that
paper, which is largely written
in English, right? The formalism is
kept in the background.
So it's a very nice paper.
Thank you.
Thank you. Andrew. Maybe mute a little
bit. Dean on the Mountaintop,
what can you throw down on us?
I don't have anything super special
throw down. I have a question, though,
and because I am very comfortable in
that fuzzy space, I kind of see
relationships and
their lack of definability as a feature.
So here's kind of my question.
So you talked about a minimum sort of
two different memories to encode
something in time. And I think it was
one of the slides just after the one
that's up here right now, which sounds
to me like somewhere processing
capacity. It sounds like we are kind of
stepping back and trying to look at this
instantaneous thing from the
relative position of even the things
that are classical can be seen as all.
So that when you mentioned that earlier,
Chris, that helped me quite a bit.
Which then manifests itself as a
classical ability to process somewhere.
I spent a lot of my career self labeling
as a wayfinder. So not capacity
realization, relationship.
Just as a relationship. It means that
wayfinding is not just an orienting or
a processing where I am and being
gripped by sort of the thing that I'm
enveloped by. It's also the channel,
the screen, the bound, the divide, the
gap, the unentangled potentiator.
It's the thing upon which traction can
exist as being a gripper as well.
I was already hung up on I wanted to go
back like Colombo in that old 70s TV
show and talk about Z spin because I
think Z spin is an energy way of
describing. But I honestly think when I
went back and watched your presentation
a couple of times, I'm starting to get a
sense that Z spin is also relationship
it's that affordance, that allows us
to be able to see up and down. But I'm
just curious, Chris, are we really
talking about processing somewhere in
the classical sense, but because we have
these two ways of encoding different
memories, we're also talking about
somewhere processing just that state
that allows for that's. My question
is that what we're really getting, are
we trying to open that up, that
possibility up?
Yeah, I think that's a nice way to think
about it.
I think we're trying to, at some deep
level come
up with a way of describing what it
means to be an agent.
And I'll say in our case, a self
conscious agent with a sense of
time that's embedded
in an environment that we
depend on to store memories for us.
And what I mean by that is that
we depend on the environment
to change very slowly,
at least from our point of view,
so that we can keep some
sense of our orientation within the
environment. Right. We're using
everything we see as a memory that
allows us to keep ourselves
fixed, which allows us to have a point
of view. So we're
using the entire visible environment as,
if you will, a reference frame against
which we can see small changes.
But if the environment was constantly
and rapidly changing, we wouldn't
be able to do that and we wouldn't be
able to use it as a memory and so we
would have no point of view. So in
a sense, I think what we're talking
about here is the
miracle of having a point of view that
gives us a sense of time.
That's very philosophical.
It's amazing. And I wonder if along with
the perspectival visual advancements
which you and. Shannon Dobson have
explored. In the math art settings.
You're almost bringing that kind of a
transformative re understanding or re
quantum reference framing into
a temporal setting where it's not just a
static spatial parallax that we
are aesthetically and formally re
understanding. But also a temporal one,
which, in an agent environment system,
necessitates these questions of
communication, which, in the quantum
information formalism, are approached
topologically rather than geometrically,
which is what we needed for the kind of
vanishing point type math art in
the spatial setting.
Well, I think they're approached
geometrically eventually and that's
really what the session in September
will be about. It's how to start with
this very topological picture
where we're only talking about
interactions in
a sense, interactions in time, but
outside of space and layer a spatial
structure on top of that.
And I
think this is particularly interesting
in this active inference context because
it immediately raises biological
questions about the
ability of different organisms to layer
space on their experience and hence
locate themselves, if you will, within
some sort of perceived world.
Awesome. Dean and then back to Ander for
the last minutes.
Oh, wait, unmute. Dean and then please
continue. Sorry.
So, Chris, is it from the pure neophyte
perspective that I have, is it OK to say
that it's not just a flipping of
position of words, that somewhere
processing, that availability and
processing somewhere in the classical
sense, where am I? It's our
ability to fuse those, as you mentioned,
we can slow down, we can stabilize, we
can see that relationship.
Or is it about spinning?
I think the former, right.
Spin is a very convenient abstraction
for talking about binary
encoding.
And we have this felt sense of spin,
but its use
in physics is very much an abstraction.
I mean, the difference between a proton
and neutron is a spin variable.
Awesome. Ander you can in the last
minutes take it where you need also
unmute and then continue. Can you guys
hear me now? So let's hope that I have
time for Chris to address a couple of
things. So just to conclude the slides
and then hopefully we get to say a few
words on quantum Darwinism. So towards
the end, the slides appear to start
pivoting towards the next subject,
which is space and time. And here in
particular, we see the earlier slide
showcasing the Lock protocol where
you can notice that half of it has been
cut and has been moved to the
future. So here we don't have two
sectors of Alice communicating, but
rather Alice communicating with its
future. Still, you have the classical
and the quantum channel. Now, one
question that I brought up, I remember
and in the lecture,
and maybe we can expand on a little
more, was exactly what is the difference
between this quantum and the classical
channel part? Something I heard Chris
say is that it is crucial for the
quantum channel to be recohered. So this
is going to be some sort of unitary
scattering evolution that is completely
independent of everything else going on.
Is that correct or should be? In theory.
Yes. And I suppose, just like
earlier, the classical channel is the
part that takes time and free
energy expenditure. Now, my question
to you, Chris, is not
the channels in the middle, but the
ticks on either side of the boundaries
that have been broken down and separated
in terms of an external time. What's up
with those ticks from one sector to the
other of the boundary? So in Q one, for
example, the lower TRF sector,
that's that amount to a state was
prepared. The upper one was I made a
memory record of that state. That's what
it is, right? Yeah.
Okay, so in the lower sector,
we both had a preparation and a
measurement, and a measurement was
recorded classically here. That's all
there is. Yeah. So preparation
and measurement are effectively the same
process.
And you can think of in
a one of T, what a one
is doing is,
from an operational point of view,
she's preparing an instrument
and turning it on. She's creating
an initial state,
and she's simultaneously encoding
a memory someplace in
her head or on a piece of paper of what
those preparation conditions were,
because it's only with respect to the
memory of what the preparation
conditions were that the later
measurement is meaningful.
Let's go back to just preparing a spin.
Right. At T, she may
set the angle of some polarization
filter that defines a propagating
beam of photons. And at
T plus delta T, she measures something
about what those photons are doing. But
the measurement is only meaningful with
respect to her memory of what
the polarization setting that prepared
the photons was.
So effectively,
what's going on in the quantum channel
is an experiment,
and it's
the classical information that's
preserved in this classical channel that
makes the experiment meaningful or
interpretable or informative. Yeah, for
sure. Yeah, that makes perfect sense in
preparation of measurement. This ties
back to an earlier question we had both
happen simultaneously at the same degree
of freedom at the boundary, or do we
have preparation at the lower bound
measurement at the top of one?
Yeah, one can think of that operator,
Mi, if you remember the decomposition
of the Hamiltonian as preparing or
measuring. It's just a matter of
interpretation effectively.
Is it acting to the left or acting to
the right? Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. Makes perfect. And then
before we get to quantum error
correction as more of a special instead
of a time thing, I wanted to ask about
yet another question between this one.
So the quantum channels does involve
some sort of time evolutionary
portion, that is, this portion that is
evolving unitarily with no interference
from the outside. However, as you said,
for this experiment to make sense, you
need to have a classical memory of how
that experiment was prepared so that
means that that classical guy on top is
static. There's no time flow in it.
Well, this actually gets back to the
talk by Suskin that we were talking
about before we started here that you
kindly referred me to.
Part of this classical memory is
memory for what counts as a classical
clock. And we'll actually get to
this again in the September session.
But if you think again about doing an
experiment in which a state is
prepared and then it's measured, this
quantum process is a process through
time with respect to some classical
clock that actually provides
the time coordinate for the experiment.
So this
classical clock is some external
reference frame that a
one here in this notation is
using as part of her classical memory.
Right. Again, it's a
memory because it's something that's
assumed not to change.
This will be kind of the heart of the
discussion in September that time
and memory and object persistence are
all different names for this same
assumption that we make about the world.
Thank you, Chris. Thank you. I am
going to have to so.
Only for now though. Yeah, only for now.
I will nonetheless persist someplace.
Thank you, Chris, so much, Chris. Okay,
awesome. See you. Thanks very much.
Measure you later.
Andrew, if you wanted to drop any other
cues or clues or bring
us a little bit of a preparation for
where we're going to be heading in
lecture five, that would be pretty cool.
Sure. So, I mean, I'm a little aware of
what's coming in lecture five.
It's about space and time and how space
may be sorry, time may be a little more
fundamental than space for reasons that
Chris will show has
a lot to do with the notion of how you
define a clock. As in we need to think
hard about what
are the bare minimum ingredients for you
to talk about the existence of a clock.
These are deep, fundamental, almost
philosophical questions that are
overlooked. And the good news, and
that's the Saskin talk that Chris and I
were referring to is that other people,
especially in the high energy community,
are also looking into these questions,
which is very reassuring. So I'm talking
at Wheaton, Suskin, Harlow,
Et are there is a recent talk
on YouTube where they talk about what
does it mean for something to be a does,
how long does a clock last? And then
Chris will also talk about space. And
the punchline of it will be that there's
obviously a physics approach to emergent
space time, which is very technical and
so on. But from what
I understood, I have yet to see the talk
myself first is that there is a parallel
biological approach as to how we learn
out spacetime. So from developmental
psychology point of you infants,
and I suppose all kinds of animals are
not Born fully equipped to perceive
spacetime. Hence the necessity of things
like play and so on. So they can find
correlations between motor inputs and
visual inputs, right? And eventually
things like the mirror test, which is
nontrivial. No human is Born
passing the mirror test already. So that
implies that at least biologically, it
is nontrivial. And it takes a few steps
until you get to have that sort of
spatial awareness. Right? Now, the
interesting part, at least for me
personally, is what the physics side of
it is. And I'm
no expert by any means, but I think the
gist of it might have to do something
with quantum error correction adseft
and so on. There was a bit of a teaser
about quantum error correction here in
these. Yeah, I mean, that's that's about
all I can say. But very looking forward
to the biology also. Yeah,
cool. Harris any last thoughts
or anything you want to point towards?
Basically, I would like to thank
everyone for inviting me. I really
enjoyed it the whole Livestream.
I hope we have made some progress
and looking forward to the next
live streams number five and number six.
So that's about it. Thank you,
everyone. Thank you. Anything else?
Andrew that's it. Awesome. Well,
I encourage everyone to go to the
syllabus page, look ahead, look back,
prejust digest, regest, ask questions
and end. Let's make progress as you
exhort. Harris so, see you all.
Till next time.